joining me now it is great to actually
have a real conversation
with a a colleague and a friend who i'm
with all the time on nfl network
especially on mondays on nfl now which i
highly recommend people watch at one
o'clock eastern time every day when it
is not super bowl week
it is the super bowl winning coach
formerly the baltimore raven super bowl
35.
brian bilik how are you sir how are you
doing young man
um i'm doing well thank you for calling
me young i'm always flattered when you
uh when you play that card thank you
thank you well relative to me yes you
are well i i understand all things are
relative i truly appreciate it
it was the 20th anniversary what last
week two weeks ago i'm told you guys
kind of had a virtual
like a zoom ravens reunion party what
was that like
yeah it was that was phenomenal there
had to have been i'm going to say
50 of the players um and they just put
us all on zoom
and kevin uh byrne who was our uh pr
uh vice versa uh public relations uh at
the time uh kind of kind of tr
you know three-ring circus that he was
the ring leader i guess but uh
it was fabulous to see the guys and uh
and they
uh you know it made me feel good because
i saw that i'm not the only one that got
old
see those guys was great though i mean
everybody was there
just brought up memories of that week
and what a special time it was and
and uh to stay reconnected we just had
some great stories
uh it was uh it was really cool did ray
give a speech
you know we did we had some very
emotional moments um
uh on it uh guys really spoke up kevin
did a nice job of
kind of breaking down and asking
different individuals to talk
and uh ray in his normal way uh got you
know
was alluding to how how big that was how
important it was particularly with all
the things that
had transpired uh as a team and for him
and
um and and uh yeah a couple of the guys
and
and and we talked to we've lost uh
regrettably uh tragically a few of those
players uh
four or five over the the last uh 20
years for a number of different reasons
so yeah he didn't he didn't do the dance
and uh but he got us fired up a little
bit it was great all right
i'm gonna i'm gonna tread carefully here
i i had
a former teammate this was uh near the
end of rey's career once tell me
that sometimes ray's speeches
that he would sit in the back of the
room and kind of roll his eyes
right now i'm not in any way questioning
his ability on the field nor his ability
as a leader nor is
his ability as an inspirational figure
for your locker room but i have to
imagine
that on zoom when everyone's staring at
the cameras
brian nobody could do that for the
reunion
no i i don't you know it's interesting
when and rey was very
um judicious with
he would during the course of the season
when i was with ray
maybe twice say hey coach i need to say
something
you know it wasn't like every week or
you know and and
and and when he did it was it was
powerful
so he yeah now now the obviously on the
field and that whole mantra
and who yeah there are times when it's
okay but who okay the dogs are out i get
it
yeah let's you know uh and and someplace
like a marriage at some point you just
yeah there are times you might want to
tune it out uh
but but uh i think for the most part the
players recognize
and the thing and the reason you did is
you you knew that was so
genuine to ray's personality this was
not i see it now with so many guys
doing it it's kind of like okay well you
know that you're not the first to do it
and there's a little pretense to it and
okay you're thinking that's maybe what
you're supposed to be doing with ray
it was true to the core to the marrow of
what he was
and what he believed so yeah it uh it
was usually pretty good stuff
all right talking to brian billick super
bowl winning head coach my colleague at
nfl network last
last question about your team because
it's now 20 years you know we're back in
tampa here
obviously for for this year's game i was
reading the piece that the athletic did
this week
about memories of your championship team
with the ravens
obviously one dominated by ray lewis and
that defense
and how things have changed 20 years
later
and obviously the bucks have a great
defense the chiefs have made enough
plays but it's all about the quarterback
the shiny object fantasy football the
points the touchdowns all that
do you think a team will ever
come along again in this offensive era
that we live in with a defense so
dominant brian that it can carry a team
to a championship
in this day and age no
no uh and and and i say that because now
obviously
i'm biased my perspective to a degree
but you got to remember our championship
and then new england and tampa's all
three teams were primarily
dominated by the defensive side you also
have to remember we were in a
in a void we were transitioning out of
the montanas the merinos the aikmans
and we were transitioning into the new
you know whether it was mannings and
breezes and
uh that group so there was a little bit
of a void there
to where yes dominant defense and and we
take great pride in knowing for a lot of
different reasons
you know we everybody kept saying well
you can't say you're the greatest until
you break the all-time scoring record
and win the super bowl at the same time
well we did
so that's kind of the benchmark okay
that's what i was told that's what it
had to be
that all-time scoring defense record and
we all know records are made to be
broken will never
ever ever be broken uh not the least of
which is the rules have changed i get
that
and and offense and just what you're
alluding to um so
that that group i think takes great
pride in that because that is a record
that will never be broken
uh but the gauntlet of quarterbacks that
you have to go through today
through the entire season in the
playoffs no it is a it's a different
environment
i lied i got one more question about
super bowl 35
because we were talking about this
during the commercial brian do you
remember who was the halftime show oh
jeez
no clue preoccupied with with uh
with the fact that it just seems like
you're in the locker room for
hours that that uh no we were
you know do we restretch and uh although
i got to tell you the best
a halftime locker room story that i've
ever heard tiki barber
who i've done a number of things with
since of course on the giant side
tells the story we know tequila tiki can
be a little irreverent
okay so they're at halftime we're
killing them i mean they're not getting
they're just this game's basically over
at halftime
and their often has got no chance of
producing
so remember sean payton was their
offensive coordinator
so he gets up at halftime tiki tells the
story he says okay
he's all fired up guys we're gonna
change the impetus to this game we're
gonna totally flip
we're gonna come out we're gonna go no
huddle we're gonna go no huddle increase
the pace of the game
and it's gonna totally throw them off
and in the back of the room
cheeky in typical tiki barber fashion
goes oh great
now we can go three and out faster
that shot but no huddle speech
thanks thanks coach and it was ten to
nothing in half
and and you guys at the half were in
there uh doing all that stretching and
what felt like an eternity for the
answer is
aerosmith in sync with appearances by
britney spears nelly mary j blige
and tremors featuring the earthquake
horns coach well i will tell you that my
daughters
when you ask them their singular memory
of that super bowl
and obviously this i mean it meant a lot
to them was they got to meet
in think they were they just went nuts i
mean they were that all they
once that happened they didn't care what
happened the rest of the weekend
wow dad won a super bowl and they got to
meet justin timberlake and everybody
yeah that was that was it that's
fantastic talking to brian billick here
my colleague at nfl network let's talk
about this game cam jordan of the saints
was on about yeah 40 minutes ago and he
said something surprising i asked him
about
the chiefs not having eric fisher and
mitchell schwartz they're they're two
left
they're they're starting tackles left
and right tackles against todd bowles on
this defense and he basically said it
didn't matter
said you know patrick mahomes is patrick
mahomes and he finds a way
not that he's superman but i said isn't
this the number one story nobody is
talking about he said no i don't think
it is
do you buy that well here's the here's
the difficult thing because we know the
tampa front
is is pretty darn good the problem is
and you're right with the tackles being
out
that i've been talking about all week
long that okay does this change the
equation
because the problem is i don't care how
good your four-man front
is if you only rush four it's almost
impossible to fill all the lanes to keep
patrick mahomes
in the pocket if you're too tight he's
gonna roll to the outside
if you maintain the edges you don't have
enough there's just too much space in
between for him to step
up and take off so you know i'm of the
belief that
you know okay if you i can see todd
bowles going okay with these tackles out
we'll see if we can get home
quickly because that's the key get home
quickly with that four-man rush on the
edges
but if we can't then you got to do a
five-man rush
you you've got to keep him in the pocket
because now he can still beat you from
there
but you know if he gets outside of it
you're dead
and the problem is though the numbers
don't add up if you give a five-man rush
then what you can do on the back end
and you got a double tree kill and you
got a double kelsey and that you i mean
just run out of numbers so this is gonna
be the dilemma
uh and i'm gonna it'd be interesting to
see earlier i can imagine kansas city's
gonna get the ball out of his hands
early
you know just to measure okay how how
vulnerable are we with the tackle
but but i agree with cam jordan to a
degree in that
patrick mahomes is so special i don't
care how good that four-man rush is
there's just too many alleys for him to
escape when he has to
you mentioned the hudia double question
we had that on the network
yesterday can you pick a poison between
those two
well i i've said it all week defensively
you can take away anything you want you
can take three kill out of the game
you can t take travis kelsey out of the
game can you do both
okay now you got a problem so you're
gonna have to change some things up
the thing that patrick mahomes is so
brilliant at and you got to know tampa i
hope for god's sake they learned you
can't go man for man with tree kill
i hope we don't see them come out and
think okay yeah now carl davis is going
to play better and we're going to go man
for man with hill
because it was embarrassing and when
they finally backed off that then they
kind of got it under control and let's
remember it was a three-point win
by kansas city uh but you you can't like
i said you run out of numbers so yes so
you're gonna have to change it up
you want to get patrick mahomes to just
have to pause a second
okay who's who's not doubled where can i
go with the ball
um because if he has the time and he can
isolate it whoever's got the one-on-one
for that play that's exactly where he's
going to including
nicole hardman if you want to double
travis kelsey you want to draw
a double turry kill and and go with a
four-man rush
he's going to find hardman or watkins
that's that that's the difficult thing
they've got answers for whoever you want
to man up
talking to brian billick here we could
talk the brady side of it but i'd rather
stick with the chiefs obviously because
of your relationship that goes back so
many years with andy reid
brian last year the narrative was man
it's going to be so awesome
let like i hope andy can win one right
and andy
finally won one what would
two mean for andy reid
and his legacy and i just by the way
before you answer i'm sorry i just asked
a legacy question which i know
can get annoying as we talk about the
super bowl day and dance well it's not
annoying but it's hard it's hard to
answer
clearly getting the super bowl last year
crossed a marker without that and andy's
had a brilliant career
over close to 20 some odd years um
but but if if it were his fate never to
have won a super bowl
that would have lingered there not that
it mattered andy is a wonderful man he's
got
a faith-based young man that a young man
faith-based man that is not going to let
winning the super bowl or not winning a
super bowl define who he is
but professionally there was that thing
was that was going to linger
you know particularly when it comes time
to talk about hall of fame status you
know and it's really never one
so that that that removed the qualifier
so now the floodgate now now it to me
it's a guaranteed hall of famer
so so it's like okay well if you want to
lock the other ones on that's great it's
not gonna
okay maybe we give it to him quicker uh
than
that now if he gets a second i think the
bigger question that people are having
is not does it legitimize or add
that next step for andy it's how many of
these could they possibly get
because with patrick mahomes and the
structure they've got going
and i mean this this it's gonna the afc
championship is gonna go through kansas
city for a while
until it doesn't which is when you look
back hey
the the browns had mahomes out it's 22
to 17.
it's fourth and nine with five minutes
to go go for it and and you could derail
like what you said there what could be
something fantastic it didn't happen
here the chiefs are uh before we let you
go coach let's do the business here
xtech shoulder pads i know you're
working with them tell me about that
yeah i've been one of the original
investors and very proud of it i mean a
small little company eight years ago and
now we're the number one pad in the
national football league
the majority of players on both sides on
sunday
are going to be in ex-tech pads and uh
same in the college rank you know
oklahoma notre dame
uh uh ohio state uh where we've become
the number one major
pad in in college football as well
they're available to high school players
and the great thing is
because these are hand-fitted pads
basically in the old days if you're a
big guy you've got big pads if you're a
little guy you got little pets
now you can form fit digitally with the
database we have
we form-fit these pads basically the
height weight playing position
injury history of the level that you're
playing at so
it's you got to protect the players
particularly you've taken the head out
of the game x tech pads is leading the
uh
leading the charge to do just that and
you can check them out at x
x tech pads at bigger point the letter x
x tech
pads dot com and use the coach
21 promo code you get 10 off your order
and when you look back at super bowl 35
or any old super bowl you see the guys
with the massive pads that almost get
stacked above their helmet it's kind of
funny
it is not like that anymore brian
billick it is always
a pleasure sir i will see you on the
television at the other place have a
fantastic weekend enjoy the game sunday
yes sir you enjoyed as well thank you
brian billik everybody my colleague at
nfl network and a super bowl winning
coach who got his kids a chance to meet
justin timberlake in nsync hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here